ja reloading my
[Music]
b what's
what's seriously do
not don't act
Sur what do
you no I'm not familiar
[Applause]
[Music]
Insurance maybe that
happen there's also you been suspended
before driv well
suspended like that nail is notice but
we're not talking about that that's old
news so we're talking about the current
news right now frig I'm not familiar
with and you're telling me that I've
been notified of
what of
what okay we're not we're not talking
about let's talk about
Sy of what suspension your license
suspension that's why I'm asking you my
license that tell me you receive no
suspension it impes knowledge
ask of my knowledge my notice of suspens
has not been notified to me at all in
any way
here so I'm I'm letting you know I have
valid insurance I have a valid license
there's no reasons of any way shape or
form that my
license of what for what for
what I'm asking why my life fin
responsibility
no stop
zero I do not drink I don't
drink I have no reason to I don't it I'm
asking hour I can smell the alol
blooding your words watching I'm sling
zero words I have suspicions that you be
care therefore I legally asking
you well let me you of something I have
zero reason to perform
anyy anything I'm
not anything number one number two I'm
not aware of my license being
supended so that's surprise to me I have
valid insurance iing Mello Insurance
I've had this for two months I used to
have regr I don't have any zero re
believe that I don't have
or that I'm under any type
of tell your
lied
what well
I forget the license forget the
insurance we will figure that out after
okay I'm ask I have bid insurance and I
have and I
can but I can I have haven't found it
yet it's in my email I haven't found it
yet but I can't I have Val Insurance why
is my license
sued I'm asking you a question I'm
asking you a question please answer my
question before I do comply to anything
three times like for what financial
responsibility what does that mean
that's all it tells me it says that you
ow money for what some sort of financial
that's news to me because I have valid
insurance myal responsibility me I'm not
saying you but I'm saying been one of
these things you didn't pay your TOS you
have child could be it Insurance child
support youing my TOS anything else is
in
irrelevant no I don't I don't have any
in I'm letting you know as a civilian to
you that I have zero taic FS I have zero
transort and it may be because of TOS
that can seem valid TOS can se but
that's news to me do you understand that
that's news to me that has anything to
do with my insurance or anything I have
to do with driving my tolls have nothing
to do with me driving that's us do you
understand okay great great 0% chance of
that happen you because I'm not under
the influence of
anything you're talking about you smell
alcohol my zero that's not irrelevant at
all because that's not
true or not I'm not I'm not going to
do you if you choose not to do that I
still have to make a decision you
understand that I'm wearing heels so me
me walking and doing go ahead if you
choose not to do that I still have to
make decision you areed you understand
that a this this video the grance that
you're doing off your body cam right
let's turn on right that's going to be
revealed in court so you understand that
what I'm saying right now is relevant
right okay please if you choose not to
do that which this is your best
opportunity to dispel these suspicions
that I have that you are here this is
your best opportunity to dispel that so
you choose not to do that I still have
to make a decision and it's going to be
less information and and that's just the
information I have right now okay also
your refusal to do
this good because I'm I'm not doing
anything wrong right now
in I am I
am
you have anything on you that's going to
us take
us be out for
me but that's your susp why you didn't
give me an
opportunity you didn't give me an
opportunity that was your was your best
opportun that was your best opportunity
out of the I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
not you really have no proof that I was
drinking any alcohol at
all so I don't I don't know why you're
arresting me for alcohol maybe
speeding that alcohol is
unlawful I'm under arrest for
speeding I don't really know why I'm
under arrest right
now can you hear me
officer
hello so I'm now requesting that you
submit to a lawful test of your breath
for the purpose of determining his
alcohol content will you take the test
no okay if you ref to take the test I
requested of you your driving privilege
will be suspended for a period of 1 year
for a first refusal or 18 months if your
driving privilege has been previously
suspended or if You' been previously
fined under 32735 215 for refusing but
you're reading me a document
additionally excuse me excuse me I'm
asking you a question though I'm asking
you a question though I'm asking you a
question I don't understand I'm asking
you a question as your civili what
providance you need to answer my
question you ask me your question okay
I'm going to ask you and then you're
going to provide the answer correct yes
okay great why are you arresting me
under your false pretenses of me
drinking alcohol because you quote
unquote smell alcohol in my breath
that's that's why you're arresting me
right now I told you qu told you all the
suspicion that I had and I said I would
perform under under to avoid arrest I
would perform the activities that you
asked me to perform to avoid arrest I
would perform those for you to avoid
arrest I said yes and you're still
arresting me after you were under arrest
it's too late at that point it's not too
late at that point I'm saying yes I
would do that if it would avoid an
arrest I gave you all the warnings but
you didn't you said will you do this and
I said no excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me I can't hear you I
don't understand what you're saying
you're not listening I can't hear you
talking over but you're you're not
listening to me I'm a civilian it's your
right to protect
excuse me officer I don't excuse me
officer you're not listening why are you
listening to what I'm saying I officer I
can't hear you I can't hear you and
you're not
listening officer I cannot hear you and
youen oh my God you're so pathetic
refusal to submit to the test I
requested is admissible I I don't
understand what you're saying and you're
not listening at all I I I no I do I no
I no you're not listening you still
refuse to take you're not listening I
have listened to you I said I would per
excuse me officer I said I would is your
dash cam is your all this is being
recorded good great okay perfect so I
said excuse me officer I said I would
perform what's it called the feel toy
test is excuse me no shut up shut up I'm
aity I'm taking your no you shouldn't
you shouldn't take that you shouldn't
take that cuz I'm asking you a question
as an officer I'm asking you a question
do you hear my question or no do you
understand my question or not do you
understand my question or not I'm asking
you a question ask you a question do you
understand my question or not yes or no
answer your question
or yes or no you have not answer my
question once I'm taking your attitude
this is hey my lawyer is going to have
all this on their on their video
civilian so it's going to be in court
that's fine you're not answering my
questions you're not answering my
questions at all all
right you haven't answered any of my
questions so I'm glad it's all on video
surveillance cuz it's going to be in
court that's great for me not for you
but for me it's great cuz you haven't
provided me anything that I need as a
civilian
I have a super good lawyer so I'm glad
I'm glad it's all going to be on video
surveillance you didn't even finish what
you were saying you wouldn't let me you
wouldn't let
me
it it's all going to be on court it's
all on video surveillance so that's fine
we can go about it that route since
you're obviously
a it's just not going to hold up well
for you in court like all the video
Severance that you have right now is
just going to hold up very poorly for
you in court so I'm
glad you have no you have no proof that
I was drinking you have no no proof that
I was doing anything wrong except for
speeding and all that is is a reckless
driving charge so everything you're
doing right now is just an inconvenience
my life for
what like I have a seven-year-old at
home like I'm not I'm not doing anything
wrong but speeding and you're just
assuming everything for
what that's what I don't understand I
didn't drink I didn't do anything wrong
I have no reason to provide you with any
sobriety tests or anything like that
because I wasn't doing anything wrong
and that's definitely 1,00% going to
hold up in court so the fact that you're
making me go through all this for
what like you're you're really pathetic
and you must have a miserable life like
I I'm sad for you
genuinely cuz I genuinely didn't do
anything wrong but
speed and that's going to hold up for me
in court and you know that because you
can clearly see that I've been through
this before so I know exactly what the
I'm talking
about It's just sad it's sad that that
this is what you do for IT living I feel
bad for
you all right you have the right to
remain silent no I don't R roll my
window up shut the up and roll my window
up shut the up and roll my window up
roll my window up roll my window up I
don't care shut up good good great can a
lawyer represent you I can why why the
would I do that roll my window up roll
my window up roll my window up roll my
window up roll my window up roll my
window up I don't give a what you have
to say roll my window up roll the window
up and finish my Miranda rights do you
not know law you pig
finish my Miranda rights finish saying
them to me that's a lot do your
job none of this is going to hold up in
court you roll my window
up my lawyer is going to make a joke out
of you and I'm going to get off on a
reckless J driving I'm sure you've been
through this a thousand times you roll
my window up you piece of make somebody
else's
rable besides mine you probably haven't
got laid in a wife is probably you
probably can't ksoll my window up
you can you finish reading the the
Miranda Rights can you finish doing that
please can you do it at least one thing
right tonight finish reading my Miranda
rights finish reading them to me you
never did that that's your job finish
reading the
rights you can Pop the trunk from inside
of the car that's what you're trying to
do don't touch me or talk to me you shut
my door and roll my window don't don't
put my hold on I'll do it myself don't
touch me do not touch me I will do it
myself do not touch me do you understand
do not touch me I don't like you you're
a liar get your hands away from me let
feem cop do that do not touch me do not
touch me do not reach your hands over me
do not touch me you're arresting me for
speeding on a DUI charge I had nothing
to drink you have no proof that I
nothing about it what about it what
about it what about it I'm a house you
tell me you tell me you tell me
you're do I don't know do I look it up
that's right you're a piece
of you're not you arrested me for
drinking when I had nothing to drink
tonight du drinking under I not smok I
do not drink that is not mine do not me
do not touch me I have a very good
lawyer this is not going to say cour do
not touch me let a
be my body do
not oh now now you're now you're going
to let me drive without a seat belt
that's to get a block you're letting me
drive without a seat Bel over my body
that is against the law that is against
the law that is against the law let a
female cop put a SEO over my body I do
not feel safe you're a liar he said you
smell alcohol in my breath that is a lie
let a female officer put a seat Bel over
my body I do not feel safe with you and
I have an excellent lawyer so please I
do not feel safe with taking off in this
car I need a female officer to put a SE
Bel over my body before we leave let
that happen do not disobey thew
let a female officer put a seat Bel over
my body do you understand what I'm
saying or
not do
you understand what I am saying or not
officer is a question mark answer me
that's your job answer
me this is all going to be presented in
court so I hope you understand that
you off you arrested me for
[Music]
speeding I don't drink alcohol do you
understand I don't smoke weed do you
understand so why is the weed in the car
I have a boyfriend he drives my car I
don't know what
the I don't know what's in my
car you understand what I'm saying to
you or
not yes or no officer
you're the registered owner of the car
do you understand what I'm saying to you
or
not yes or
no people like you just make me sad for
civilians where you're so pathetic like
you have one job protect and serve
you're not doing either give me a ticket
for speeding that's your job that's it
you're arresting me for a DUI when I
don't drink and I don't
smoke
you need to request a female officer to
get a seat belt on me before we leave so
please do
that cuz you you physically can't touch
me so please do that cuz I don't feel
safe at all I don't feel safe with you I
don't feel safe in my environment you're
definitely fucking horrible at your
job your wife cheat on you or some like
dud something like what's your
problem FYI sober not sober anybody can
quote unquote feel the field sobriety
test you understand that right like
that's your perception it's not a fact
or an unfa it's it's your perception on
my breath it's not a fact or an
unfa
no no I'm not closing that it's no
that's my right to have it open it's my
right to have it
open it's my right to have it open it's
my right to have it open it's my right
to have it open it is my right to have
it open it's my right to have it open
it's my right to have it open it's my
right to have it open it's my right to
have it open my right it is my lawful
right it's my physical right it's my
right it is my right as a citizen of the
United States to have it f open it's my
right it is my right I can have it open
it's my right you cannot shut it that's
why it's
there it's my right to have it open you
can't shut
[Applause]
it we switching you to another car thank
God you stop you going to be calm and
Cooperative don't talk to me listen to
me I'm getting
out you are not don't physically don't
touch me your body camera is on do not
touch me do you hear when I'm stage I'm
going excuse me don't touch me I'm
physically capable of getting out of
this car and getting into the other car
do not fucking touch me don't touch me
don't tou
you're for
what what do youi DOI drugs she's like I
got to figure out if she's habitual or
not she's suspended a whole bunch of
stuff oh shit you got that or no well
she was fighting with me through the
window I started bleeding so I probably
should yeah we
that yeah she your gun she was yeah
there's blood all over that
from
it's on the inside yeah you got some
back here
too might as well